first of all congrats on the movie thank
you so much um I definitely think about
your character and this is you have a
very you have a small but critical role
in the film
talk a little about reading the script
for the first time and what you took
away from it I mean as soon as I read
the script and especially you know the
big kind of scene between Hal and
Catherine I was so impressed at just
impressing and just like pleasantly
surprised that the voice that she had
been given in the story because I think
you know women were not often afforded
that kind of that kind of voice at that
time period to really say how they felt
and and you know I think maybe that did
give them a position to give them a
perspective that the men didn't have
because they weren't involved in all the
kind of power thirsty you know
structures that were going on then
because they were kind of you know
disregarded a lot more than they are
today and so I think that her position
and the script and the way that she kind
of caps off the movie was was really
refreshing to see and I think a really
nice way to to end the movie I mean her
you know the entire movie how was being
advised and being counseled by all these
people and all these men whose
intentions were not really sure of and
you know they might not be for his
benefit and so I think that seeing her
at the end of the movie deliver you know
speak truth to power in the way that she
does in such a kind of calm level-headed
way and you know be so sure of what
she's saying to her what she's saying is
so obvious into him it's kind of like
you know this big revelation I think is
you know speaks to her you know just how
smart and strong she was anything blew
it when you're watching the film like
all the level of detail the production
design the costumes everything is just
so well done what is it like as an actor
when all of that is given to you and
then you're stepping on set I mean it
was it was like overwhelming in the best
possible way I mean I think that you
know anytime that you're stepping onto a
project and you're only shooting for a
few days I feel like it can be kind of
intimidating and you know nerve-wracking
especially working with people that I
admire so much whose work I admire so
much but I think it honestly just kind
of fuels the the energy and the urgency
and like the desire to do as you know
best job that I possibly could but I was
so impressed with every
as soon as I stepped on set I mean the
the hair and makeup the costume design
you know the set set everything were so
so beautiful and the music the score the
Nicholas pray tell did you know is so
incredible I just feel really really
proud to be you know even a small part
of it
sure I would imagine so you watch that
you've seen the film yes so you watch
the film are you happy or sad that you
didn't have to be in that huge battle
scene in the mud I mean I think it
wouldn't I think it wouldn't really make
much sense I mean maybe blue many people
would like to see Katherine get you know
down down and dirty in the in the mind
but I think you'd I you know I think
that she comes in at a really kind of
critical point in the movie you know how
is maybe kind of realizing that all of
his his his associates or his advisors
kind of you know don't have the the
intentions that maybe he thought they
did and I think she comes in at a really
crucial time to tell him you know hey
like wake up you know it's almost like
she's kind of known this all the whole
time and she's been observing and she's
also kind of sussing him out a little
bit like figuring out who is this person
that I have been betrothed to and you
know Lewis he's just killed someone to
give my people and like you know we're
gonna have to talk about that and
everything my last question for you I'm
big fan of Neil burger oh really amazing
and so I'm big fan I'm just curious what
you can tease about the project you did
with them it sounds very interesting it
was really interesting we just wrapped
like a month or so ago it was one of the
most incredible experiences I've ever
had one of the yeah I've never
experienced anything like it and I think
the movie will be really cool really
interesting I'm excited to see it myself
he's coming tonight actually oh well
there you go
on that note thank you so much for your
time thank you grats on the movie thank
you so much nice to meet you